i gave a commencement speech two days
ago
and
they showed a little series of clips of
me when they introduced me you know they
were watching a long clip from third
rock from the sun ah
and a little bit from footloose and ah
dexter
they showed shrek and they went berserk
[Music]
shrek
you know you're just in a sound booth
giving
a bunch of raw material to a bunch of
strangers behind a glass booth
uh the only person with me was
one of their
staff who was there only to feed me my
lines i never acted with eddie murphy or
mike myers or cameron diaz i only acted
with him
and he did such a great job as the
gingerbread man that he became the voice
of the gingerbread man
there's a little piece of trivia for you
run run run as fast as you can you can't
catch me i'm the gingerbread man you're
a monster i'm not the monster here you
are you and the rest of that fairytale
trash poisoning my perfect world
now tell me where are the others i went
and recorded stuff and i met with these
animators and the directors and they
were delightful people
but they would describe these visual
jokes to me like the funniest thing you
already like he's he's very small you
know we forget you're big he's small
there's a scene where the first time we
see him we would put him in a horse
on a horse in armor and the armor is
for a tall man but
when they take him off the horse they
take him out of the arm it turns out
he's short i thought that sounds very
funny uh like
who are these people i was the only
actor who had ever visited them and i
walked through this place this is still
a year before the film came out to all
these computer cubicles where all these
animators were working
one was in charge of nothing but milk
being poured out of a pitcher into a
glass
one was in charge of only leaves blowing
in the wind
one was in charge of mud when a wheel
went through the mud
working on this for months
in this technology that not many people
had used yet and i suddenly realized i
am in something history making and i
didn't even know it
third rock from the sun
i absolutely loved third rock it was uh
it was the creation of bonnie and terry
turner a comedy writing
married couple
whom i knew from saturday night live i'd
hosted it in three times in the 80s they
presented this
character who was brilliant in every way
except knew nothing about human
behavior or emotions and they had
constantly got everything wrong but he
could try out anything he could sing
cole porter in close harmony he could
play the piano after just spending about
seven seconds figuring out the
difference between the black and the
white keys at heart third rock and the
sun had a very serious premise it's like
figuring out how to be an acceptable
human being you know you know there i
have very few rules in my career but the
the last one i hadn't broken was never
do an episodic tv and my agent called
and said your friends bonnie and terry
are in town and they want to have
breakfast with you and i said oh great
so i went off to have breakfast with
bonnie and terry at the four seasons it
fell to terry to pitch this series to me
and the first sentence he spoke was it's
about this group of four aliens
and about five minutes later he'd
persuaded me to do this it was such a
fantastic premise
for a a nutball character actor
and they had written it with me in mind
and if i hadn't done it they wouldn't
have done it this was just the moment
when i was thinking i got to do
something other than these these
cornball villains
yes
we can lie
on our taxes
i can't believe that no human has ever
thought of this before
okay wait a second you guys what if we
get caught how can we get caught
all those other dopes out there are
telling the truth about their taxes
the writing staff was so incredible they
were so smart
they had such a great
combination of smart and stupid
in their humor it was just this pendulum
swing they went back and forth
a lot of them had come out of the
simpsons
families would watch these together and
the kids would love it for one reason
and the grown-ups would love it for a
totally different reason but they would
laugh at the same jokes
dexter
i got a terrific pitch from clyde
phillips he and john goldwyn the
producer sat with me
at caa and banished my agents they said
no nobody else can hear this and you
can't tell anybody about this but we are
going to tell you about the trinity
killer where no one said they were
thankful for me
did you jonah
and they told me the entire
detailed unfolding story but i kept on
saying well wait a minute whatever what
happened to the baby you know things
like that
and they would have to tell me and i
would kept on saying more and more more
to the point where they had given me way
way much more information than they
intended but they were trying to
persuade me to take the part and having
heard all of that
i said no i won't tell anybody any of
this but
no i'm not doing that
so
and then
my agent and my lawyer got on my case
and said john you've got to do this so i
said yes
and had a great time doing it but the
curious thing was
i gathered i met all these wonderful
actors in dexter this whole company of
actors they had kept all this
information from them so i was the only
person who knew
harry and the hendersons
i read it and couldn't quite take it
seriously it just struck me as a big
bigfoot movie
the most persuasive thing was when i met
with bill dear and he showed me the
renderings for for harry and
steven spielberg was plenty persuasive
he was the executive producer so i said
yes
and uh
yes it was a bigfoot film but it was as
good as it gets for one thing there was
a beautiful actor named kevin peter hall
who played harry and he was like andy
circus another actor playing the halfway
thankless role of
of a creature you never hear his voice
it's fun you know it's going to be kooky
but you've got to play it for real
there's a moment in
toward the end of harry and the
hendersons that every kid remembers
where
harry is in great danger and i have to
tell him to get the hell out of here to
run away and he won't go because he
wants to stay with our family
leave us alone
i pretend to be furious with him and i
smack him in the face
and he looks at me with this terrible
feeling of betrayal and you know we
intended this to be a heart-rending
moment
but we were still in this big bigfoot
movie
so how just how heart-rending is this
gonna be
well i have a cousin who's
who went through a very unhappy divorce
and the nine-year-old boy acted out
really
and
resisted and he was terribly upset the
seven-year-old girl had no response at
all like a
zombie
until she saw harry and the innocence
and that scene
she
just
exploded with grief
and she was beside herself for weeks
and
it unlocked her and she it was something
she absolutely had to go through
the crown
when we rehearsed the crown we didn't
even rehearse scenes we just talked
we talked and talked about the history
and
uh the relationships
i asked about my height you know i'm 6'4
churchill was 5 foot 7.
i said what do we do about that
and steven said just ignore it don't
think about it at all he felt the same
way about
makeup
it's like just
give the audience little credit you
don't have to give them
total accuracy
in the course i was a little concerned
that we were spending so little time
talking about the actual performances
here
i brought an apple and the apple baller
to the rehearsal and i said here let me
just show you something that i have been
working on stephen this was about with
10 of us just sitting at the table and i
made little melon balls and i stuck them
in and when we did read a thing and
i thought it was extremely effective
but bit by bit my entire mouth was
filling up with like apple cider
that was the end of that but they were
way ahead of me they had already thought
about making these uh silicon
plumpers whatever for
have we not enough qualified pilots to
take him where he needs to go no he
wants to fly himself
it's a boyhood dream it's what he's
always wanted why was government not
consulted because it's a private matter
and i am in favor nothing you or his
royal highness do is a private matter
and the father of the future king of
england risking his life needlessly is
quite unacceptable please i went to
drama school in london many years ago so
there's this sort of
english thread i'm i'm about as english
as an american actor can get to a point
of
pure pretension you know when you think
about churchill he's as different from
every other englishman as an any
american is
it's he's an eccentric they just loved
the idea they said we've all we've seen
all the sirs play churchill we've seen
burton do it and albert finney do it and
there was a whole raft of them that year
and all of them englishmen churchill's
mother was an american for one thing
that's the first thing stephen told me
when i asked him why'd you cast me
and he had this affinity for america
i may be terrified of playing this role
but they think it's a great idea so i'll
go with that
footloose
you know i'm not a religious person
i grew up in eight different places
there was never even the opportunity to
become part of a religious community
even if my family were so inclined which
they weren't
but i
i felt i had to find someone and i went
and got some spiritual counseling from a
very very
kind and
empathetic and smart man who talked to
me about his deep
relationship with jesus
and i really needed to hear that missing
from your lives
praise the lord in singing
we took it really seriously just the
emotional life of this family motivating
the role of shaw moore and his
particular almost tyrannical hole he had
on this community finding the roots of
that it was because his own son had died
in a car accident on a crazy night
and he was not going to let this happen
again
and it made him far too protective of
his daughter
and his religiosity took second place to
this just emotional
inner emotional life and his fear
we took that film seriously and a lot of
other people did too
cliffhanger
[Music]
your friend just had the most expensive
funeral in history now it's only you
i have to tell you cliffhanger was the
best job i ever had
we were four months in italy i worked
maybe a fourth of the time we were high
up in the dolomites for two months
and it's like skiing on weekends and
staying in a chalet in cortina dampenzo
and then two months in rome working at
china chita in a studio right next to
where fellini was making a commercial
for banco di roma you know pretty much
my own flat out action film
and i was even in the big climactic
brawl with the hero and the hero was
sliced alone it was like wow at the
total top of the action film
food chain it was like as good as it
gets
do you know what real love is crystal
no
sacrifice
as eric quaylen i had no idea as a
matter of fact i think i had been cast
as the sort of second villain
my role was supposed to be christopher
walken
but he bailed and they sort of moved me
up like the night before it was so we
and i remember sitting around with
rennie harlan trying to decide what
nationality eric qualen was was he an
american secret serviceman maybe a south
africa south african or how about an
englishman you know
it was literally that and i said you
know i i don't think i can master south
african overnight
and i think we should make it something
other than american
let's just go let's go the alan rickman
route but it was fabulous you know i
wish i had a nickel for every time
someone's asked me to
to say
do you know what love is the payoff is
sacrifice
you know it was like the works
[Music]
the changing room
i came out from under the wing of my dad
who had hired me for my first acting
work and i was not getting hired as an
actor at all but i was getting hired as
a director
in fact i was even offered
the job of associate artistic director
of a
very estimable rep company and i
accepted it i just was getting nowhere
and two weeks later that long wharf job
came through
and i pulled out
pissed them off no end but that was the
big a very early fork in the road that's
when this 22 cast play 22 actors men
all set in a is kind of semi-pro
rugby locker team and a
changing room in the north of england of
course it was quite notorious because
of these 22 actors 15 of us at some
fleeting moment appeared stark naked i
was the most nude of any of these men
the scene where i was uh
where i was injured
i had to be sort of
the mud had to be bathed off me
off stage then i was brought back
glistening and naked and and dried and
dressed as if i were a little baby it
was an extraordinary scene but
right out of the gate appearing that
nude on broadway that was almost more
than my mother could handle
on the other hand
i've appeared nude about five times
since then in an extremely varied career
and every time i've won some major award
so let that be a lesson to all you young
actors
[Music]
bombshells
i hate being the story i'll call trump
you go on vacation stay above it all he
won't dent your ratings nobody stops
watching because of a conflict
they stop watching when there isn't one
there was a reflexive revulsion to even
the name roger ailes not just because of
his misconduct charges but because he
represented
everything that's gone wrong with with
broadcast news with the creation of fox
news
even though i think
fox news would not not be quite the
horror it is today if roger ailes was
still alive
the challenge was
sympathy for the devil you know finding
what it is about this human being
that is the source of both his power and
people's loyalty and even affection for
him
my great confederate was connie britton
playing his wife
because you believed absolutely in her
love for him and her
devotion and loyalty to him
smartest thing i did was to track down
an old friend of mine from the 70s
who
used to work as roger ale's producing
partner
when roger wanted to be a new york
theater producer not many people know
that but it's true he even produced
the premier
production of hot l baltimore
pulitzer prize-winning play
and i talked to my old friend steve
about roger back in those days and steve
was a very good friend of his
loved his company loved his sense of
humor said he was a man capable of
sharing a laugh for 20
seconds you know but that was
invaluable you sort of had to have that
information you know the most
fascinating thing
about doing a person with an ugly
compulsion
is to
contemplate
how he felt about his own compulsion
surely he it's something he didn't want
to have to do it was the same with the
trinity killer
[Music]
the old man
copying me on all the raw data you pull
in i should have my eyes on everything
as well and
do me a favor close the door
i've got another name that we have to
track down but i want
you guys to do it no one else okay he is
a company man
the thing that's fascinating about him
is the enormous emotional baggage he
carries to me there's a great tension
between his
impassive
public face and the way he has to
operate in his job with the fbi
he and his wife have suffered a
catastrophic loss they've lost a
grown-up son and a daughter-in-law in a
car accident
and they've inherited a five-year-old
grandson to take care of that's the very
first that's information you learn in
the very first scene you see him you
see him playing with chuck with a child
sitting on the edge of a bathtub sobbing
for mom and dad
in case somebody figures out
how to bring them back someday
finally i got to work with jeff
and it was
completely fantastic
you know you get to be my age and you
finally get to work with a lot of people
you've been waiting to work with for a
long long time and and and the payoff is
simply wonderful and in in this past
year
it's been jeff
and
de niro and dicaprio and julianne moore
that's that's been my bumper crop of of
new colleagues this year but jeff is the
best of all i mean we had the best time
because you really do get
a scene in which you learn everything
about them their past and their present
and their current crisis
and it's a long long scene in a car
driving across the moroccan desert which
happened to be in santa clarita
we couldn't go to morocco as it turned
out because of covet
took us six days to shoot this scene so
that's six days in a car with jeff
bridges
and he was so
much fun just
a wonderful guy to act with
of course but also just to get to know
interestingly enough we had we had mics
on so the entire crew of about 40 people
were basically listening to jeff and i
become old old friends over the course
of six days
we would we would be talking very very
earnestly and intimately about issues in
our lives and then suddenly realizing
wait a minute
we're sharing this with everyone or
there was an entire afternoon where we
were telling jokes
and we would tell each other a joke
reached the punch line and we would hear
the laughter of about 40 people
and butterfly
i read this script and it was like
my god it just like caught fire in my
hands wildly theatrical and full of so
many
challenging ideas
but rehearsing that play
that fast
and that boldly with
you know with him and david huang so
much in tune with each other and bd wong
in his very first broadway show he he
won every single award there was to win
for for playing sunglee ling the
man whom i fall in love with without
knowing he's a man we
performed it in washington dc at the
national theater a theater way too big
for it
it got a terrible review in the
washington post
the only paper that matters in dc it
called the play preposterous and in fact
the premise is preposterous
we were convinced we were take taking a
dog to new york
and it was like
new york audiences had been waiting for
this play for 20 years it was it was
like an explosion going off
the world according to garf
i'm sorry i mean all i did was just
touch her it's all right she can't bear
to have a man's hand touching her or she
got problems yeah she does i mean it's
going to be kind of hard to avoid being
touched isn't it yes it is that's why
she's here
my name's roberta
i'm garp
you're jenny's son yes i am oh i just
finished reading your novel i think it's
wonderful i adore i had read the novel
like everybody else never occurred to me
this would be a movie it struck me as a
book you couldn't possibly make a movie
out of particularly because of one
absolutely
key scene
just thought you just can't do this
scene in a movie it was a very radical
choice to make this
this really
kind of the essential friend
of the of the hero
a transsexual
as they were referred to then
interestingly enough when i first met
with george
hill
to
just basically
read for him
he ruled me out immediately for being
too tall
particularly because i was so much
taller than robin williams she just
won't work it'll be just too much
pushing it too much but eight months
passed i was in despair because i
thought i was the only one to play this
part i went back and i screen tested for
it with three other actors among them
jeff daniels by the way just by chance i
had read this book called conundrum the
memoir of
jan morris the travel writer who had
actually undergone
trans surgery and and i just sort of
spouted the things that i remembered
from reading this book two years before
and he was like
my god you new york actors you do so
much research not at all it was such a
privilege to work with george roy hill
he's one of three or four of those mount
rushmore kind of filmmakers i got to
work with back in the
back in the 80s bob fosse and brian de
palma a lot of these
great old-timers came out of 50s
television where they rehearsed actors
to perform live in front of the whole
nation we simply rehearsed it like a
play
with george and his cinematographer
merrick undercut sort of wandering
around figuring out everything before
the even
the first day of shooting
and
i
remember the first
scene i shot
was a scene in which i as roberto was
tied to a tree and garp and his kids
were clowning around with me and i was
playing the damsel in distress
[Applause]
[Music]
and at the end of that day of shooting i
went to george and i said george
rehearsing is one thing this
i mean i'm i'm not that used to the
camera i
i feel that i was i just didn't i was i
overd was it too much just i mean how do
you feel and he said
well i'm glad you brought that up
and my
heart just
sank into my
stomach and then he roared with laughter
and he said ah no i was fine if there's
ever any problem i'll be sure to tell
you
and that was like the last direction he
ever gave me
he was just such an old-timer such an
old marine
the movie is
first of all he was so ahead of its time
you see it now
and you think my god this was a movie
made for right now
i mean just think of what's happened on
the whole issue of
robi wade and abortion right now how
it's been politicized and how fanatical
people are on the subject